micah is with us in Saginaw Michigan hey
Micah what's up I'm doing pretty good
babe how about you better than I deserve
how can I help
well so I have I haven't RN degree I
have a bachelors and I got accepted into
CRNA School in the fall and my question
kind of stems from this I have all my
student loan debt paid off as of now
good
during CRNA school you're not allowed to
work um just because number one the
program is so intense and then obviously
the programs two years long so I plan on
obviously taking student loans out again
which I did the I've already done once
um my I have a house now and my question
is should I rent my house out for extra
cash coming in while I'm in school or
should I just Bank sell my house and
walk out there in with like liquid cash
what's your house what's your house
worth um right now I'm estimating about
115 120 and I know 60 minutes okay and
what a CNRI school cost
I'm hoping it's less than 120 but that's
about what I've been figuring okay
120,000 that seems that seems a little
steep what's that that's high oh okay
for CNRI real high like almost double
what it should be
we're in the crap are you going to
school yeah I mean that's what I figured
in living in Causton oh that's concluded
living okay that's not paying for school
okay yeah I can relax a little now I
thought you I thought you're getting
ripped off so you're paying what sixty
okay so my double was not far off okay
good that's more like it and you think
you're going to need 60 to live and
you're going to get 60 out of this house
yes okay and you're single
yes
and it starts in the fall it starts in
August so right now I had like roughly
monster oh yeah somewhere else so much
to claim for it and you're currently a
nurse yes okay I have a challenge for
you I want you to go do this debt free
you have surrendered to this culture of
debt and I want you to not surrender
this culture of debt and here's what I
would do if I woke up in your shoes the
great news is you're a nurse you're
single and I want you to work 90 hours a
week between now and August and I want
you to sell your house and I want you to
have enough money to do this dream okay
you're not gonna do it are you
ohh whining me a river cry me a river
called the wambulance nurse I mean
seriously you're gonna go in debt
because you don't want to work now I
can't help you at all okay look you're
gonna pay this one way or the other you
might as well pay for it upfront it's
not freakin free money and don't be
normal you listen if you want to do it
you want you do whatever you want to do
but you call me what would I do if I
woke up in your shoes I think you have
the ideal degree field nurse you can
work ER until you collapse Oh go do it
you're young believe me nobody died from
hard work right before you died you pass
out you know that it's a medical term so
really you're gonna be all right Shh and
that's what you do